the women the babies they are being
murdered they are being beheaded the
elderly ladies sitting and waiting for
the bus are being shot multiple time by
machine guns and they're posting the
pictures online and then Washington Post
journalists are liking tweets that say
what did you think decolonization meant
yeah did you think it meant Vibes losers
that happened her name is Karen AA she
writes for the Washington Post I follow
her you know why I follow her because
she's a BLM supporter she's with Kendy
and D'Angelo and all the lunatics but I
like to get the viewpoints of people who
I disagree with and she's one of
them do you now think we're just in this
for a while like do do you sense that
sort of shift that I'm talking about in
the world that like I I just don't think
that this thing's going away for a while
I don't even mean just the specifics of
the violence I mean just like whatever
it is now on earthing I I sense we're in
it for a while and then you throw it a
presidential election which is still 13
months away I mean everyone thinks it's
tomorrow and it's 13 months away like it
seems to me we're now stuck for a
bit Yeah I think for a bit but I I am
very hopeful that a change in leadership
at the top can change things I really I
am now look I'll be honest um Trump
brings with him such a bag of you know
baggage that that will add a new level
of chaos to it all there's just no
question about that so I do think
another Republican leader would probably
bring less less of that chaos
but who who's kidding whom like if
president Trump were in the office right
now do do any of us believe this would
have happened I don't believe that no no
as critical as Ukraine yeah no 100% I'm
with you yeah we wouldn't have had
Afghanistan and I realize he wanted to
withdraw from Afghanistan but I don't
believe for one second that he would
have done it the way that Joe Biden did
it and I think he would have changed his
mind if he had seen any sort of of
wobbling uh by the afghanis on the
Defense Force but so I don't think we
would would have had Afghanistan I don't
think we would have had Russia and
Ukraine and I don't think we would have
had this atrocity with Hamas and I do
think Trump's instability you know in
messaging in temperament when it came to
foreign policy was a benefit to us you
know Rick grenell tells the story of how
Angela Merkel looked in his eyes and
said like I don't know what your gu's
going to do next and he had to stop
himself from smiling you know and and
bombing sulamani the Iranians didn't
know what to do they were afraid they
were like holy right bomb sulamani
and they were too weak and too afraid of
him and us to do anything in response so
right everyone said it was going to
start andus of the guy right everyone
said it was going to start World War II
and it gave us actually three years a
peace and how many mid east peace deals
and and the rest of it so so all of this
daav is by by way of saying I I am
optimistic that we can regain stasis
that we can regain a steadiness that has
been missing for the past couple of
years and I'm pretty pretty sure that
what we're feeling right now is akin to
what our parents were feeling in the 70s
after a couple of years under Jimmy
Carter that instability starts at a very
high level and trickles down he's been
pushing all this he opened the
Border he's allowing this myth about
boys becoming girls and rewarding it
being taught in schools he's pushing the
racial essentialism and dividing us from
you know K through 12 and Beyond in the
classroom he and his allies in Academia
even Corporate America and Beyond are
are festering allowing to Fester these
lies which are dividing us and making us
feel disconnected patriotism on the way
down religious observance on the way
down and the weakness being projected on
the on the foreign policy front I really
think a lot of it starts with the
American president and it was a severe
mistake for Americans to put him in
office who who do you think is driving
that because I I think you basically
said this already you don't believe that
Biden's really driving the ship right
now there's some other you know everyone
has their own theory on this whether
it's Obama in a in a Biden costume or
it's the Obama people or just like some
version of something this does not seem
like Joe Biden is in charge I think
someone basically hands him notes he
poorly reads them fumbles off the stage
and then we just do it again the next
day do do you have a sense of really
where this is coming
from I wish I knew I mean my best guess
is if it's not Obama himself it's all of
his disciples because who Joe Biden
hired uh and you remember that that one
appearance where Obama came back to the
White House and how the entire staff
ignored Biden and went right over over
to Obama unbelievable that that was very
telling but I I really I wish I knew I
don't think it is Joe Biden and I don't
think you know I I go back to things
like all of the rewards that he's
creating or trying to create at the
college level scholarships and so on for
people who write just the perfect BLM
message who who major in ibra X kendi
nonsense sense you know he's doing this
he's trying that's not Joe Biden he's
the biggest racist elected to president
in I don't know good 25 years well we
got our clip for today's
show seriously I mean there's not the
week goes by that he doesn't say a new
racist thing he's not pushing BLM
nonsense so who is that it's I think
it's the leftover woke Obama crew I mean
look at Obama it's how long did it take
him 48 hours to even bother to put
together some anod tweet on these
atrocities like his heart wasn't in it
so I don't really know the answer Dave I
wish I did you know the closest I've
seen is that Easter Bunny who he really
seemed to listen to but I don't know
who's inside the costume that's what I'm
saying it's Obama in the Easter bunny
costume it really could be um yeah it's
just it's it's because it's also like
it's something that's dis it's why
everyone's going nuts basically that's
what I think is that we all know these
things that are so obvious like Joe
Biden's not running it and that boys
actually are boys and girls girls but
we're so hit with these things and then
all the entire class of people who were
supposed to say you know say the truth
they all completely failed and then
we're just like oh yes beheading women
is okay because everything else is
broken why not like that's really where
I think we're at this is what's so crazy
I mean you that sounds like a laugh line
like you just taking something that
actually happened and making an
absurdity out of it that actually is
happening like the the women the babies
they are being murdered they are being
beheaded the elderly ladies sitting and
waiting for the bus are being shot
multiple time by machine guns and
they're posting the pictures online and
then Washington Post journalists are
liking tweets that say what did you
think decolonization meant yeah did you
think it meant Vibes losers that
happened her name is Karen AA she writes
for the Washington Post I follow her you
know why I follow her because she's a
BLM supporter she's with Kendy and
D'Angelo and all the lunatics but I like
to get the viewpoints of people who I
disagree with and she's one of them but
she seems like in her personal life kind
of a nice person she posts pictures of
her cat she posts pictures of her
workout she exess okay she expresses
insecurities from time to time she you
know and I I I do it for intentional
purpose I like to remind myself that my
adversaries on policy or ideologically
are not necessarily evil you know
they're we disagree very strongly but
like I like to like some of her posts
about her cat Dave I don't have a cat
I'm a dog person but I'm just saying
like it makes me feel good that I can
still see the humanity in this person I
it's just my own personal private thing
this person liked the tweet from this
lunatic activist
saying what I just said about
decolonization this is what it looks
like you're a loser if you don't
understand it okay babies are being
decapitated so you can right off
your cat and your Tweet it's over
unfollow this is the thing that was a
bridge too far for me I can understand
differences on all the other stuff and
it's it's not even about exactly the
Jewish thing it's about the humanity
thing you know like where is your
Humanity I don't get how you can look at
that beautiful group of Israelis dancing
at the Rave for peace that's what that's
what they said they were out there for
having a good time as like only a
22-year-old can do out under the Open
Sky and see them murdered in the
absolute not even the prime of their
life in the part of the life where
everything is yet to be enjoyed and say
haha that's a win yeah you go that I
don't have anything in common with those
people I can't like anything about them
in my own head it feels like it's War
it's on I you're
despicable you know no one ever gets to
the end of the argument and I think
Megan Kelly just got to the end of the
argument and it's so freaking refreshing
I didn't I didn't say the f bomb because
I've dropped it like 20 times on my show
in the last two days so I'm glad that
you handled it for me okay so so I get
you on those people but what do you
think we do about now we have what I
refer to as the Hamas caucus we have AOC
we have Rashida Talib we have ilhan Omar
and the rest of them um what's the other
one's name uh I got it uh yeah Cory Bush
ET yeah thanks she's such a faker at
least a couple of those are Palestinian
American Cory Bush she's like living out
of her car and posting BLM slogans two
minutes ago yeah now she wants us to
look at her as an authority on Israel
Palestine sure sure oh sure Jan okay but
what do we do about these people look I
you know how how I feel about Free
Speech but I think we are getting
perilously close where if you constantly
defend people who are calling for
genocide and murder and beheading babies
and everything else and always excusing
it and then you connect that to the
people that are in Time Square calling
for all these things and showing Nazi
Flags we're I don't think this is
exactly the neo-nazis marching in skoki
Illinois and the uh uh NAACP standing up
for them anymore I I don't think that's
where we're at I think we're veering
into something else what do you think
what do we do about this do you think
their allegian is to the Constitution
that they Swear to
protect um I I'll say this my first
instinct is I like that they're posting
these tweets it completely exposes them
in a way that you know few other like
they've done controversial things it's
been pretty clear people like Anan Omar
are anti-semites for a long time if
you've been paying attention but this is
just so clear like it's kind of good to
see them posting these statements and
really taking away all doubt it's
wonderful actually now we'll always have
these statements so we can always
dismiss all of their arguments because
we understand that these are vile people
um and anybody who is persuadable will
agree with us anybody who doesn't agree
with us we know that they're in the club
too they're also anti-semites there's
absolutely no reason to support what
they're saying right now so I kind of
like the fact that they have a forum and
that they're being exposed I find it
much more problematic at the
universities that we have hundreds and
hundreds of students coming forward to
blame Israel for all of it yeah like
that's that is I mean that's that's what
Harvard says Harvard says we raise
tomorrow's leaders and they're not
entirely wrong and for them to have 31
student groups blaming Israel for all of
this and it's not just Harvard Stanford
Berkeley Yale Northwestern George
Washington I could keep going putting
out statements and then in some of these
cases the university President says
nothing in response we're seeing it like
at the lower at the high school level
too uh students coming out who Don't
Know Jack trying to make supportive
statements of Palestine of Hamas they
they don't know what they're doing so
that actually is problematic to me
because those people are going to move
into positions of power real power the
squad is marginalized for all of the bad
she did Nancy Pelosi kept them
marginalized and that was one win in the
Pelosi file and they're still
marginalized they're just such a small
group and I just think it's not totally
without value to have them squawking so
people who are sane can point to them
and say is that what you want to sign up
for if you're looking for more
uncensored opinions from today's thought
leaders check out our media playlist and
if you want to watch full interviews on
a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell